- [Instructor] In other videos,
we've discussed the causes and effects
of westward expansion in the 19th century,
focusing on the period that
began with the discovery
of gold in California in 1849
and ending shortly after the Civil War.
But westward expansion was a long process.
Eight new states entered the Union
between 1876 and 1896.
And not until nearly the
turn of the 20th century
did the superintendent of the US Census
declare that the frontier was now closed.
US territories stretched all
the way to the Pacific Ocean.
We've talked a bit about what
caused people to move west
and what effects the
immigration of millions
of non-native people
west of the Mississippi
had on that region and on
the United States as a whole
before and during the Civil War.
In this video, I want to pick up the story
after the Civil War and
discuss how westward expansion
affected the society
and culture of the West
at the end of the 19th century.
Let's quickly review some of the causes
of westward expansion that
were already established
by the end of the Civil War.
Starting in the 1840s,
Americans and European
immigrants began moving west
looking for farmland.
And the California Gold Rush of 1849
brought people from all over the world
into the region to either pan for gold
or to make some money off the people
who were panning for gold.
The construction of the
transcontinental railroad
also provided many jobs for
those who didn't strike it rich.
The US government facilitated
this westward expansion
by granting millions of
acres to railroad companies,
making it easier to get west
and to get goods from the West back East.
The government also encouraged settlement
through grants of 160 acres of free land
to anyone willing to improve it
over the course of five years.
Lastly, many American
migrants were convinced
through cultural messaging
that American civilization
was divinely ordained
to occupy North America
from Atlantic to Pacific in an ideology
known as Manifest Destiny.
All of these things continued
to motivate westward expansion
in the years after the Civil War,
but there were a few unique aspects
in this era that intensified the changes
wrought by westward expansion.
First, the US government
began to take a new approach
towards its interactions
with Native Americans.
Instead of treating Native American tribes
as independent nations,
the government began
to cast them as wards of the state,
relics of an earlier time that had to take
up American ways or face extinction.
They began to confine Native Americans
to reservations and
classify any individual
or group that refused as hostile.
Another related thing that changed
was that after the Civil War,
the US Army could apply its full might
to subduing the West through
a series of conflicts
with Native Americans
called the Indian Wars.
One thing I find fascinating
about these conflicts
was that many of the
generals who led campaigns
in the Indian Wars were
former Union generals
who had fought to end slavery in the South
during the Civil War,
including Oliver O. Howard,
the commissioner of the Freedmen's Bureau.
What do you think their
approach to Native Americans
versus African Americans
says about how they conceived
of American citizenship
in this time period?
The effects of westward
expansion also intensified
after the Civil War.
As we've already mentioned,
one effect of Americans' westward push
was violence against Native Americans
and other minorities.
The US Army forced Native
Americans onto reservations
or hunted them down when Native Americans
attempted to prevent white settlers
from encroaching on those reservations,
like when gold was discovered
on the Sioux reservation
in the Black Hills of South Dakota.
The US Army also
prevented Native Americans
from engaging in rituals
like The Ghost Dance,
which they feared would kindle resistance
among Native Americans.
In 1890, an Army regiment disarmed
a Lakota Sioux encampment
near Wounded Knee Creek.
And while the Lakotas were
giving up their weapons,
one rifle accidentally discharged.
The US Army then massacred somewhere
between 200 and 300 men,
women, and children.
Other minorities in the West
were also subject to racial violence
including Mexican Americans,
who were driven off their lands by force,
and Chinese immigrants, who were targeted
in race riots throughout California.
Minorities also faced
the loss of their land
and their cultures in the West.
The most significant land
loss came as a result
of the Dawes Act of 1887.
The Dawes Act sought to
force Native Americans
to stop living communally
and take up American culture
and farming by splitting up reservations
and awarding 160 acres of land
to each head of household,
sort of like the Homestead Act.
But unlike the Homestead Act,
Native Americans had to improve the land
and behave like whites for 25 years
to get title and American
citizenship, not just five.
And due to corruption in
administering this policy,
Native Americans were placed
on the worst land for farming,
or their land allotments were given
to white settlers instead.
All in all, the Dawes
Act resulted in the loss
of over 80 million acres
of Native American land.
Similarly, government
agents turned a deaf ear
towards the claims of Mexican Americans
whose land was claimed by white settlers
even though Mexican Americans
had been US citizens
since the end of the Mexican War.
The same impulse to force Native Americans
to assimilate into
American living patterns
also drove the creation
of Indian boarding schools in this era.
Native children were
removed from their homes
and sent to boarding schools
like the Carlisle Indian Industrial School
in Carlisle, Pennsylvania.
There they would be forced
to cut off their long hair,
change into American-style clothing,
and take up new American-sounding names.
These schools lasted until the 1970s.
Chinese immigrants, by contrast,
were judged incapable of assimilation.
In 1882, Congress passed
the Chinese Exclusion Act,
the first immigration restriction
to prevent all members of an ethnic group
from entering the United States.
Restrictions on Chinese immigration
would not be completely
abolished until 1965.
There were also some
far-reaching environmental transformations
resulting from westward expansion.
One of these was the near
extinction of the American bison,
also known as the buffalo.
Huge herds of buffalo
roamed the American West
for all of recorded history in the area.
Plains Indians had over-hunted them
in the years before large-scale
immigration to the West,
but the coming of the railroad
signed the buffalos' death warrant.
There were about 15
million buffalo in the West
at the end of the Civil War,
but less than 20 years later
there were fewer than
1,000 buffalo remaining
due to whites hunting them for sport
or clearing them from rail lines.
This left Plains Indians,
who depended on the buffalo
for meat and clothing,
in a state of near-starvation,
making it even more difficult for them
to resist being forced onto reservations.
Plains Indians were also affected
by the development of
barbed wire in this era,
which white settlers used to fence off
what had been communal grazing lands.
This was also a hardship for cowboys,
who once had driven herds
of cattle to railroad depots
over long stretches of open range.
By the end of the 19th century,
there was little to no
open range left at all.
Lastly, the spread of settlers
into the arid western
part of the Great Plains
led to massive irrigation projects
in order to supply lands
that weren't really naturally
suited to farming with water.
This meant damming and diverting rivers
and the use of farming techniques
that would later contribute to the ravages
of the Dust Bowl in the 1930s.
Who has access to water
and for what purposes
is still a major source of conflict
in the American West.
So as we look forward
into the 20th century
from our vantage point here at the edge
of the American Frontier,
let's take some time to think
about what the story of westward expansion
tells us about how Americans
thought about citizenship
and access to resources
in this time period.
How will those ideas
influence the United States
once it begins to step on the world stage
and look for new frontiers
outside of North America?